welcome everyone uh to our webinar on
how teaching kids to read went so wrong
sponsored by Yale's Institution for
social uh and
Yale's Institution for social and policy
research or isps for short
um and we're also co-sponsoring this
event with the Yale education studies
program uh executive director of that
program is Mira Debs and so thank you to
our co-sponsors
um before we begin I want to recognize
some of the outstanding colleagues at
isps who helped organize our events
especially Pam green Rick Harrison and
Kira wishart thank you all so much for
all the support you give to all of our
events
um I'm Alan Gerber I'm director of isps
and today I'm excited to provide an
opportunity for you to hear some of the
insights of Emily Hanford an award
winning reporter and podcaster I will
introduce her shortly
this event is part of isps's democratic
Innovations program which is designed to
identify and test ideas for improving
the quality of democratic representation
and governance one of the major research
priorities at isps is to understand
governance and a big part of governance
is how well government services are
provided education is a critical
government responsibility and so I'm
very pleased that we have a chance to
reflect on how we are doing at meeting
this basic and essential Collective
responsibility
a couple of logistical matters Emily is
going to speak for 25 or 30 minutes
after she's completed her presentation
um I may ask a question or two we're
then going to open things up for General
q a
um that Eric potashnik will be helping
to manage and that the event is going to
run until around 5 15. so we have about
75 minutes to
um to meet together today
um I want to encourage you all to send
questions for Emily at any time through
the Q a button at the bottom of your
Zoom screen
please keep your questions uh brief and
on topic and we will do our best to
answer as many as we can
um to help field questions again
um I don't know Eric I should introduce
you a little bit
um Eric is the Julius Rabinowitz
professor of public policy and chair of
political science at Brown University
and he's an award-winning author of
books on a number of topics in American
politics and public policy and
administration
so thank you Eric for your for your help
today
um I also want to let everyone know that
today's event is being recorded
um and so we hope to be able to share
the link for this video as soon as
possible after the event if you'd like
to watch it
um multiple times
um so let me tell you a little about
Emily
uh Emily Hanford is a senior
correspondent and producer for American
public media her work has appeared on
NPR and in the New York Times the
Washington monthly the Los Angeles Times
and other Publications she has won
numerous honors including a Dupont
Columbia University award and the
Excellence in media reporting on
education research award from the
American educational research
Association Emily is a member of the
education writers association journalist
Advisory Board and was a long time
Mentor for ewa's new to the beat program
for the past several years Emily has
been reporting on early reading
instruction her 2018 podcast episode
hard words why aren't kids being taught
to read when the inaugural public
service award from the Ewa
you can find all of her reporting on
reading at
apmreports.org backslash reading
including her new new podcast which I
think is a is a major hit and it's a
it's compelling listening
um sold the story how teaching kids to
read went so wrong and I should just
finally add that I think it's it's very
fair to say that Emily has the
distinction of being a person who has
really changed the national debate on a
matter of importance to everyone and
that is
you should everyone should be so lucky
as to as to be able to uh see their work
have that kind of impact and so
um so it's a wonderful privilege to have
Emily visiting with us today
um welcome Emily
thank you for having me
I've already gotten one text that
then although it seems like we're all
we're all on Zoom but I'm here in New
Haven and I'm really glad to be here
having a I've had a wonderful day so far
met a whole bunch of students and
faculty and I'm really
um grateful for the invitation
so I'm just going to talk for a little
while
um I thought I would just tell you a
little bit about myself
um tell you sort of some of my story
about how I got interested in this topic
and some of what I have learned about
reading and how it works and how kids
learn to do it because I actually think
it's really fascinating and I think many
of you
um maybe don't know I certainly didn't
know so you can put up the first slide I
have some slides this is actually just
uh the first one is just a couple of
kids in a classroom in California and
this is the goal happy little readers
right and the question has always been
how does a little kid get there like how
does a kid learn to read so you can go
to the next slide
this is my kid I have two kids I have
two boys so this is my little one and uh
when my kids went off to school I really
didn't think about how they were going
to be taught to read I I definitely
didn't think about whether they were
going to be taught to read I just
assumed they would and they did without
much trouble so this is my younger one
this is a few months after he started
kindergarten and he's reading a chapter
book and I truly I don't have any idea
how we learned to do that it just kind
of seemed to happen it was like magic
um and school was actually a really good
experience for this kid he's now 20.
he's a sophomore in college and it was
for my older son too who's a college
graduate it was for me too uh and I
think the fact that school was pretty
good for us had something to do with the
fact that reading came pretty easily
but here's the thing that I have learned
that I didn't know reading doesn't come
easily to a lot of people uh and it
doesn't have to do with intelligence
there are lots of really smart people
who struggle to learn how to read and
they can learn to read they can but they
really need someone to teach them how to
do it to show them how it works and
there was this moment when I started to
understand this in a way that I never
had before and it was actually here in
Connecticut it was the winter of 2016.
and I was interviewing college students
who had been placed in remedial reading
classes and these were students who
graduated from high school they went to
college and they were told wait a second
you're not ready for this you're not
ready for college
and I the instructor in one of these
classes told me about a student that she
had had a lot of years earlier her name
was Sarah
and the instructor could tell that this
student was really smart and driven and
she wanted a college degree because she
wanted to be a nurse but Sarah wasn't
going to be able to pass the assessment
that was going to get her out of this
remedial reading class she couldn't read
very well at all she couldn't write
and the instructor ended up petitioning
the English Department
saying Sarah's really bright she needs
college degrees so she can be a nurse
let's figure out some way to assess her
get her out of this class so she can
move on and get a degree and it worked
Sarah passed the class and then this
instructor whose name is Jill lost track
of Sarah she thought about her sometimes
she wondered about what had happened to
her
and then years later Jill was in the
hospital having surgery and she woke up
and there was Sarah Sarah was Jill's
nurse
so when I heard the story I thought I
really want to talk to Sarah so uh Jill
dug up an old email address I wrote to
Sarah Sarah went back to me and in the
winter of 2016 I drove to her house in
Connecticut in the middle of an ice
storm and we did this long interview and
Sarah told me all about her reading
problems
now it turns out that Sarah has dyslexia
that was not something that was ever
identified when she was in school it
actually wasn't anything that was like
ever officially diagnosed it's basically
what Sarah figured out about herself
and Sarah told me about all these
strategies that she had to try to get
through the written text
so there were a certain number of words
that she had just memorized she knew
what they look like like common words
she saw all the time and then there were
a lot of other words and she would just
guess them she would look at the first
letter look at the last letter think
about something that made sense
and she told me the problem was she
couldn't come up with a very good guess
a lot of times so she just skipped a lot
of words and this way of reading was
really time consuming it was hard it was
frustrating it was confusing she
couldn't focus on the meaning of what
she was reading so really her main
strategy with reading was just to avoid
reading she really didn't do it she had
this sister who was a little bit older
than her who would read things out loud
to her and that's really how she got
through school how she got through high
school then she got stuck in that
remedial reading class in college she
got saved by her instructor she eked her
way through college without opening a
book she told me never she said she
never opened a book in college
and her strategy was to pay really close
attention to the lecture in the class
discussion she says she has a really
good memory I believe her and that's how
she got a Nursing degree
she memorized all the words that she
needs to know to be able to read and
write communicate with the nurses and
the doctors and the medical staff
but she really never learned how to read
and her story was really amazing to me I
had all kinds of questions after talking
to her about dyslexia first of all I
knew nothing about it about why she was
never identified with dyslexia didn't
get any help in school so this next
picture which you're looking at stay on
this slide I just started to dig into
this question of Dyslexia and learning
disabilities and there's tons of
research about this so this is just one
little part of my bookshelf these are
some of the books that I started reading
so I was digging into the research about
dyslexia
and then I was also talking to parents
and I was starting to hear the same
story from parents all over the country
first I was talking to parents in
Maryland where I live and I thought oh
my gosh Maryland has a terrible problem
and then I was talking to parents in
California and Michigan and Florida and
really literally it was the same story
over and over again and the story is
basically this like our kid went to
school and we knew something wasn't
right we went to the teacher and the
teacher was like don't worry make sure
you read lots of books to him
everything's going to be fine but we're
like something's not right with reading
here he doesn't seem to get it he
doesn't like it this went on for years
the parents would say there's something
wrong here and the school is saying
don't worry we've just got to find your
kid the right book he'll get really
excited and it'll all be fine
and what eventually happens these
parents were telling me if they had time
and money especially money money is a
big thing here these parents would pay
for private testing to try to figure out
what's going on with their kid and this
usually costs thousands of dollars a lot
of these parents would turn to private
tutoring which is more thousands of
dollars sometimes they'd hire a lawyer
or an educational consultant or both to
actually like start a fight with the
school to try to get what their kid
needed and it's really expensive really
frustrating really hard really
exhausting
and what happens is the parents begin to
realize that their child isn't going to
get what he needs in public school or
he's not going to get it fast enough
because now this kid is like 9 10 years
old he hates school he can't read very
well so he's falling behind in other
subjects uh sometimes this kid is acting
out in school like maybe this is turned
into a behavior problem or maybe this is
starting to manifest as like anxiety
depression withdrawal and this is when
the parents tell me if they have the
resources time and money money money
money the family pulls their child out
of public school so maybe they teach
themselves I've met a whole bunch of
mothers who quit their careers to teach
their children to read to homeschool
their kids or maybe they come up with
the literally tens of thousands of
dollars like maybe even eighty thousand
dollars a year at some schools around
here that it can cost to send a kid to a
specialized private school and there's a
whole bunch of parts of the country
where there isn't a good private school
to send the kid to even if you could get
them in even if you did have the money
so what I started to realize is that
we're we're in this situation in this
country that if you can come up with the
money to pay for it you can probably
find a way for your kid to be taught how
to read but if you don't have the money
and your child is not learning how to
read in school
what do you do
so the equity implications of this are
really stunning if you're from a low
income family even a moderate income
family there's really no safety net here
there's no backup if you're not being
taught to read in school one mom said to
me getting help for a struggling is
reader or struggling reader is a rich
man's game
so I was like whoa what reading this is
the most basic thing here this is the
foundation upon which all learning is
built so how did that happen
how is it allowed to continue what was
going on so I did this next reporting
project you can go to the next slide
and this is what Alan um mentioned uh
hard words it's an audio documentary
about core reading instructions so first
I was really interested in dyslexia what
do kids with dyslexia need but now I was
like okay not let's not think about what
struggling readers need in particular
but rather what do all children need to
learn to become good readers like what's
up with this how do we learn to read and
what I discovered is there's this huge
body of evidence about reading and the
bottom line from that evidence is this
decades and Decades of research what
kids with dyslexia need to learn to
become good readers is not substantially
different from what all kids need to
learn to become good readers like we all
need to learn the same things to become
good readers kids with dyslexia need a
certain intense like dose of a certain
kind of instruction but all kids can
benefit from the kind of instruction the
kids with with dyslexia desperately
desperately need so I started digging
into all this research about reading so
you can go to the next slide
so this is the part of my shelf of books
that slide before this
um this is just questions about how do
we read how do our brains learn to do
that uh how do we learn you know what do
we need to know what do we need to be
taught why do some people struggle with
reading why is learning to be really
hard for some people because it is it's
really hard for some people and a lot is
known about this a lot is known about
reading and why kids struggle and
there's actually research that shows
that different reading methods affect
reading development so different ways of
teaching kids to read you can actually
like see it in their brain so you can go
to the next one this is a book that
taught me so much and I highly recommend
this book reading in the brain it's not
light you can see I don't think I've
ever put so many sticky notes in a book
and there's a big takeaway from this
book and from all this research and
maybe it seems kind of obvious but it
wasn't obvious to me is that our brain
is actually the product of millions of
years of evolution in a world without
writing right so for as human beings we
just didn't do this reading and writing
thing for a long time so our brains
actually aren't like wired to do it
we're not born with brains that are
wired to read it turns out that some of
us don't need to be taught that much we
don't need very much instruction but
some of us need a lot so you go to the
next slide
this is really the book that sort of
blew my mind about all of this it was
written in 2017 by a guy named Mark
Seidenberg who's a cognitive scientist
at the University of Wisconsin and it
made me think a whole lot about a lot of
assumptions that I didn't realize I had
about reading and here's a quote from
the book by Mark Seidenberg
reading to Children rarely involves
teaching them to read
the activity contributes to the child's
progress but it is not all that is
required some children do learn to read
with minimal instruction but unlike
learning to talk it is a mistake to
assume that they will
another quote from this book is children
who are read to and tell the cow jumps
over the moon can still have difficulty
becoming readers
so this book is about that and it's also
about politics and policy and teacher
preparation and what teachers learn and
really more like what they don't learn
about how kids learn to read and how to
teach it it goes into the reading Wars
and ideas about how kids learn to read
theories about it that we've been
fighting about for centuries
the sold a story podcast that I talked
to you about before at one point we went
way back in history actually we have a
timeline that starts in the 1600s and at
one point we had this whole section in
there where we talked about the reading
Wars back in the 1800s
and they were just drop down horrible
bitter fights
and they really started because this guy
named Horace Mann who you've probably
heard of who's like the father of public
education was the first Secretary of
Education in Massachusetts and he came
along with this idea he believed in this
particular method about teaching kids to
read
and it was called the whole word method
and Horace Mann believed this these are
quotes from Horace men children learn to
read by being in the presence of books
and then he said this
I am satisfied that our greatest error
this is Horace Mann our greatest error
in teaching children to read lies in
beginning with the alphabet no thorough
reform will ever be affected in our
schools until this practice is abolished
so Horace Mann did not like the idea
that kids were going to be taught about
the letters and the sounds that make up
the words and language he thought that
was going to be tedious and boring and
that it was unnecessary in fact this is
one of my favorite quotes from Horace
Mann
he said in regard to all the other
sources of pleasure Beauty motion music
memory the alphabetic column presents an
utter blank there stands in silence and
death the stiff perpendicular row of
characters lank Stark immovable they are
skeleton shaped bloodless ghostly
apparitions and hence it is no wonder
that the children look and feel so
death-like when compelled to face them
so I think it's important to recognize
that one of the founders of public
education felt very strongly about how
to teach kids to read and he really
thought it was going to be a bad idea to
start with letters and sounds to start
with phonics he thought that was going
to be bad for kids and then the Boston
School Masters and this guy named Samuel
green who is the principal of the
Phillips grammar school in Boston
we're listening to Horace Mann and
reading things he is writing and they're
like whoa wait a minute Horace hold your
horses and they wrote this retort to
Horace Mann which is fascinating in
their very 19th century away and they
wrote things like this
reading justly deserves the first rank
among the studies of our schools as an
accomplishment alone it possesses
intrinsic Excellence but considered as
fundamental to other Departments of
learning its value cannot be too highly
estimated so they're saying hold on
Horace you are talking about something
critical here you're coming up with this
new idea to teach kids to read and we
don't think that this is a good idea
they said in judging the merits of any
system by which reading may be taught
remote as well as an immediate effects
should be duly regarded a child even at
the threshold of his education should
not be subjected to any delay which the
formation of correct habits may require
he should never be hurried over
difficulties at first concealed yet in
his progress unavoidable simply to make
his entrance into the Temple of Learning
Easy and agreeable a system of
instruction is subjected to an unworthy
test when the chief Excellence claimed
for it consists in smoothing the path of
the learner so essentially Horace Mann
was saying let's make this easier for
kids to learn to read by not focusing on
the letters and sounds and the stuff
that's hard English spelling is hard
let's just get kids into books and words
and get them right there to the end and
the Boston School Masters are saying
wait a second you're going to try to
make this easy at the beginning by just
getting kids into books and not teaching
them letters and sounds getting putting
the hard stuff on the side but you are
going to damage those children in the
end and no one could agree should you
start with the way that Horace Mann was
saying sort of meaning first whole words
whole sentences whole stories or should
you start with letters and sounds
a sort of bottom-up approach emphasize
decoding right and we fought about this
forever because no one really knew but
then all this research started being
done sort of exploded in the 1970s
motivated by the question how do kids
learn to read like seriously how does
that work so you can go to the next
slide
and this is something I talk about a lot
um I think it's a really good place to
begin because it really really helped me
understand how reading works it's called
the simple view of reading and the
simple view of reading does not say that
reading is simple really important to
the contrary reading is actually really
complicated it's complex but the simple
view of reading is a simple model to
understand a complex process so it was
first proposed a long time ago I was in
high school it was 1986 and this model
was actually proposed because these
researchers were trying to clarify the
role of decoding and reading
comprehension because everyone was
fighting about this this was sort of
when the reading Wars of the late 20th
century were getting into full swing now
everyone agrees that the goal of reading
is to comprehend text everyone agrees on
that and the question is how does a
little kid get there so the simple view
says that reading comprehension is the
product of two things right so one is
your ability to decode the words right
and the other part of the equation is
your language comprehension so that's
your ability to understand spoken
language so we're not talking about your
ability to read text language
comprehension is your ability to
understand meaning when someone is
talking or when text is being read out
loud to you so for example when someone
says to you she is reading the book you
know what the verb means in that
sentence you know what she's doing so
what the simple view says is that if you
have really good language comprehension
skills but zero decoding skills your
reading comprehension will be zero
because zero times anything is zero and
the simple view also says that if you
have really good decoding skills but
very poor language comprehension skills
you just don't know the meaning of that
many words in spoken language your
reading comprehension will not be very
good either so so here's why this is
important most kids entering school have
very little when it comes to the
decoding part of the equation right they
have zero or close to zero when it comes
to the D in the simple view of reading
but they do have something when it comes
to the language comprehension part of
the equation so when kids enter school
they know the meaning of lots of words
if they're English speakers in in
America but they don't know how to
decode those words yet right so this is
why people familiar with the science of
reading so-called to call for an
emphasis on decoding instruction in the
early grades because of the goal if the
end goal here is to try to get to
reading comprehension and you have a
bunch of five and six-year-olds who are
sitting in front of you they have
language comprehension skills but they
really have virtually no decoding skills
you need to help those children develop
decoding skills but and this is so
important the simple view clearly shows
that focusing only on decoding would be
a very very big mistake because it's
only part of the equation and this is
really important kids come into school
with very different language
comprehension skills right some kids
know the meaning of lots and lots of
words some kids are far smaller
vocabularies some kids are speaking
little or no English
So reading instruction that aligns with
the simple view has to focus on this
language comprehension part of the
equation too
so I was in this first grade classroom
where reading instruction was
deliberately aligned with this simple
View and what I saw was phonics
instruction in one part of the reading
instruction and the kids were broken
into small groups depending on the level
of their decoding skills and then in
another part of the reading instruction
they were getting explicit vocabulary
lessons and lots of reading Out Loud by
the teacher
and the words that the kids had learned
were posted on cards all over the
classroom they were words like
extraordinary and ridiculous and
neighborly which are not words that the
vast majority of first graders are going
to be able to decode they shouldn't be
expected to but the first graders in
this class were learning the
pronunciation and meaning of those words
so that when they're able to decode them
they'll know what the words mean and
this is really important every single
child in that class spoke English as a
second language and for some kids
English was their third language so this
simple view was proposed as a model back
in 1986 and then the basics of this
model have been confirmed over and over
again by research since and I think it's
really helpful because it disentangles
some of the stuff that's really
contentious in the debates about reading
and has been for for decades for
centuries right so when what's known as
the whole word which sort of became the
whole language which is now more
recently called balanced literacy so in
the whole language balanced literacy
view the Focus right from the start of
reading instruction should be on getting
kids to focus on the meaning of know
what they're reading that's what Horace
Mann wanted whole language and balanced
literacy are meaning emphasis approaches
to reading instruction get kids to focus
on the whole the meaning as opposed to
what's known as a code emphasis approach
which emphasizes decoding skills at the
beginning of reading instruction right
so early reading instruction that aligns
with the scientific research over the
past 50 years is a code emphasis
approach not only but emphasizing so
that kids can get to meaning because
everyone agrees that meaning is the goal
and the question again is how does a
little kid get there
so in my reporting when I became very
interested in trying to figure out is
how are kids being taught in school
that's what I started to dig into next
so let me just tell you a little bit
about what I learned you can go to the
next slide
this is just one little artifact here it
was sent to me by a mom in Massachusetts
it came home in her son's backpack and
these are all strategies for kids to use
when they're learning to read and they
come to a word that they don't know and
here's the thing these strategies make
sense they seem totally sensible you get
to a word you don't know what can you do
well you can look at the picture to try
to figure out what the word might be you
don't want to completely guess so you
can look at the first letter like Sarah
did for example you can look at some of
the letters it's going to narrow your
choices help you come up with a good
guess you can then check you can see if
you were right reread the sentence using
the word see if the sentence makes sense
uh maybe you were right if you're really
stuck you can just skip the word and
move on skip hopefully you can get the
gist of the sentence anyway so what I
was trying to understand is I was seeing
stuff like this all over the place like
on postcards on bookmarks there are
these little cartoon characters that
have versions of these strategies this
was everywhere in American schools I was
seeing it in classrooms I was visiting I
was getting sent it parents were telling
me about it and I was like what is this
about what is the idea about how reading
works that these strategies are based on
that's what I wanted to get interested
in and that's what I started to try to
figure out so you can go to the next
slide it turns out that these ideas are
based in a theory a theory about reading
that's been along for around for a long
time
that's come to be known sort of more
recently as cueing not everyone uses
that term but the idea is that readers
use different kinds of information or
cues or Clues to identify the words as
they're reading and this was sort of
articulated as a theory back in the
1960s and it was sort of a big deal it
was a big deal in the research area when
this Theory came out and the basic idea
behind this queuing Theory remember this
is the 1960s we really didn't know how
people read yet the theory here is that
readers don't have to sound out written
words to know what they are they can
right they can send out the words but
they don't have to because they can use
other strategies to figure out the words
they can do things like look at the
first letter of a word use the context
think of a word that makes sense look at
the pictures they can essentially
predict the words as they're reading the
problem is this is not the way that
skilled readers do it this is not the
way that skilled readers read so you can
go to the next slide
I did this reporting project in 2019
where I was just I got really interested
in this queuing Theory and how this
Theory and the word reading strategies
based on this Theory became foundational
in Reading curriculum reading
assessments and reading intervention
programs that are very popular in
American schools that say they use a
balanced literacy approach to teaching
reading and surveys show that most
schools at least until recently said
they used a balanced literacy approach
queuing is at the foundation of that
balanced literacy approach but this
cueing Theory as I said isn't right it's
not how skilled reading works cognitive
scientists showed this back in the 1970s
and 80s skilled readers when you're a
good reader you do not use cues and
context to identify words as you're
reading in fact
this is the amazing thing what
scientists figured out is that this is
how poor readers read right struggling
readers often have a hard time with word
identification too many of the words
that they come across are kind of like
little Mysteries little series of
letters that they don't know and they
can't quite figure out so like Sarah
they have all these other strategies
that they use to try to figure out what
the words say right and often they don't
like reading they just get a gist of the
reading get they guess and Skip and use
context this is not what reading is like
when you're a skilled reader what
cognitive scientists have figured out is
that this really is the key difference
between skilled readers and unskilled
readers
unskilled skilled readers can
immediately and accurately recognize
words they don't need to guess or
predict or use the context
and skilled readers once you're a
skilled reader if you're a skilled
reader you actually know tens of
thousands of words in a split second
like instantly on site in fact if you're
a skilled reader your brain has gotten
so good at reading words that you
process the word book faster than you
process a picture of a book which is
really amazing because remember your
brain was not designed to do it so how
did your brain get so good at that so
I'm just going to take another couple of
minutes to explain it another couple key
Concepts and then we're going to move on
to questions but it happens through this
process called orthographic mapping
and I think it's really key to
understand a little bit about
orthographic mapping to understand why
teaching kids how to decode words is so
important why phonics is important and
why teaching kids the queuing strategies
is not a good idea so yes to phonics no
to the cubic strategies so here's a
quick and simplified explanation of
orthographic mapping it's basically the
process that we use to store printed
words in our long-term memory and here's
how you do it you attend closely to how
a written word is spelled and you link
that sequence of letters to the words
pronunciation and meaning so it's three
things the spelling the pronunciation
and the meaning so for a very simple
example a little kid knows the meaning
and pronunciation of the word cat and
the written word cat gets
orthographically mapped to her memory
when she links The Sounds at to the
written word cat so that requires an
awareness of the speech sounds and words
that's called phonemic awareness it
requires an understanding of how those
sounds are represented by letters that's
phonics so you need good phonics and
phonemic awareness to orthographically
map words into your memory and once a
word has been orthographically mapped to
your memory you know it instantly on
site in fact you cannot suppress your
ability to read the word it's
fascinating you don't have to
consciously sound out the word when you
see it but you know the word in a split
second because at some point maybe when
you were like eight years old or five
years old at some point you successfully
sounded the word out and you link the
spelling of the word in your mind with
the meaning and the pronunciation of
that word
so by about second grade a typically
developing reader who has good phonic
skills needs just a few exposures to a
word through its pronunciation its
spelling and its meaning and Bam the
word is mapped to her memory more words
that you map to your memory this way the
more you can focus on the meaning of
what you're reading you're not using
your brain power to identify the words
you're using your brain power to
understand what you're reading and
that's the goal right for readers to
understand what they read we're reading
but when teachers use that queuing
system when they teach all those word
reading strategies they are actually
impeding that orthographic mapping
process so you can go to the next slide
I'm just going to tell you this one
little story and then wrap up so these
are first graders in Oakland California
and a literacy coach who worked with
these girls came to see that teaching
the queuing strategies was actually
making it harder for many of your
students to learn how to read
the coach's name is Margaret Goldberg
she was hired by the Oakland Unified
School District back in 2015 to teach a
program called level literacy
intervention lli is a reading
Intervention Program that does include
some phonics instruction because
remember one of the cues for figuring
out a word is to use the letters but lli
is rooted in that idea that foundational
idea and balance literacy that letters
are one way to figure out a word
so kids are also taught that when they
come to board they don't know they can
use pictures and context to try to come
up with a guess so Margaret started
teaching this lli program and then at
about the same time she found this bunch
of unopened materials sitting on a shelf
in her school which you'll find all over
America and is part of the problem and
it was a systematic phonics program and
phonemic awareness and it teaches kids
that when they come to a word they don't
know they sound it out and it does not
include any of the queuing stuff and in
this program beginning readers practice
reading in decodable books books that
contain words with spelling patterns
they've been taught so they don't have
to guess at the words they don't have to
use that strategy
so Margaret started teaching some of her
groups of students lli with the queuing
and some she taught this systematic
phonics and phonemic awareness program
with no cueing and she started to notice
differences between the two groups of
kids not just in how well they were
reading but in the way they approached
their reading so she and a colleague
recorded first graders talking about
what makes them good readers so this is
a video we're going to play it for you
Mia is in the white shirt she was
learning phonics and no queuing and
gibria is in the pink jacket she was
taught the queuing system so you can
play the slide yes what makes you good
readers
I learn a lot because I look like the
pictures and I read it
do you remember when you were little and
you didn't know how to read
[Music]
um
oh
like when you started kindergarten yeah
what helped you learn how to read how
did you learn
anything else looking at the words and
sounding them out
so Margaret was seeing this over and
over again and these two groups of kids
like one group of kids was taking away
this idea from Reading instruction the
idea that reading is about looking
closely at words and sounding them out
and the other group of kids was learning
that when you come to a word you don't
know you don't have to look carefully at
the word and try to connect the spelling
with the pronunciation and the meaning
instead you can look away from the word
you can look at the pictures you can
look at the other words in the sentence
search around for Clues to help you
identify the word but remember that
orthographic mapping process requires
you to look carefully at the word so
your brain links the spelling with the
sounds and the meaning and this queuing
stuff teach teaches kids to actually
look away from the words
so what Margaret Goldberg said to me
about the kids in her lli groups was
this I did lasting damage to these kids
it was so hard to ever get them to stop
looking at a picture to guess what a
word would be it was so hard to ever get
them to slow down and sound a word out
because they had had this experience of
knowing that you predict what you read
before you read it
so you can go to the next slide this
sort of tees up the sold a story podcast
which is
um really my uh effort to figure out why
how did it happen that this idea became
so predominant in American schools not
just in American schools but in schools
in other parts of the English-speaking
world too like I said we had this
unbelievable timeline that started in
1649 it has 2019 entries as of yesterday
and it is about one idea
the idea is kids don't need to sound out
written words because they have other
ways to know what they are they can
sound out the words but they don't have
to the whole thing is about what's wrong
with that idea and how that idea came to
dominate in American schools and the
Damage that idea is done six episodes
four and a half hours that's it
the debate about how to teach children
to read has long been about phonics and
has been understood to be about phonics
and getting reading instruction right
though is not just about adding phonics
instruction it's about taking away that
cueing theory and I think most
importantly helping teachers understand
what's wrong with that theory
uh and I think you do that by helping
them learn how to read and when teachers
really do learn how kids learn how to
read then they sit there and they can it
sort of falls apart on its own this
whole queuing Theory they're like why
why did I do that and we can get into a
little bit of that in the conversation
but I'll just tell you a few things
about the reaction to sold the story
it's got had lots of listeners it's I
think it's 5.3 million listeners so far
lots of people who aren't Educators who
aren't the parents of struggling readers
that was really one of my goals I said
to my editor early on like I really want
the moms of the kids who's who aren't
struggling to write to me and say I
listened and I care about this and I
want to do something about it and that
is what's happening I think the parents
of struggling readers have felt alone
for a long time and they're finding each
other and there's more of them than you
realize and I think this is something
that all of us need to care about even
people who learned how to read easily in
spite of how they were
um taught another thing that sold a
story has done is that legislators and
at least 15 states have introduced some
kind of build overhaul reading
instructions since it came out there was
a big wave of legislative effort going
on before that so this has really been
happening over the past several years
and I think a lot of it has to do with
parent advocacy
but one of the things that's happening
now
and these bills is that a lot of them
are focused on curriculum and some of
them are specifically focused on Banning
curriculum that includes this queuing
idea at last count as of yesterday there
were 10 states at least that have
introduced some kind of queuing ban
which I have some mixed feelings about
which we can talk about I mean the point
of this podcast was that this idea is
debunked and harmful and breaking its
decades long hold on education system is
really important but these Bands Make Me
anxious and you take something away
everyone's suddenly looking for
something new I'm worried about there's
a sort of a rush to buy new things I
don't think buying something new is the
answer I don't think a new curriculum is
going to solve all the problems because
at the end of the day this is really
about teacher knowledge teachers teach
kids curriculum don't teach kids and
banning this queuing stuff is taking
place at a time when lots of other books
are being banned so I think there's a
danger here that this could all get
caught up and corrupted bipartisan
politics and we tried this once before
uh in America and it did get caught up
and I think sort of killed by partisan
politics so I think I'm going to skip uh
the rest of the stuff I was going to say
because I think I've talked too long and
I would really love to get to your
question so I'll just wrap up there and
I'm looking forward to this discussion
okay thank you so much Emily um that was
that was great and I I want to say also
the um the podcast it's it's super
educational and also really interesting
and I think you um
you really breathe a tremendous amount
of life into the science of of reading
and phonics and and um orthographic
mappings and things like that I I'm not
surprised that millions of people have
um have have have uh listened to your
podcasts and and that it's had the
impact that it's had I wanna
um remind our participants uh please ask
questions
um uh when will you get the opportunity
to ask Emily Hanford a question
um well now is is when you'll have that
opportunity so so um so please send your
questions and then Eric batashnik is
gonna
um gonna filter those and um turn them
into maybe groups of questions and
things like that for um for Emily but
let me ask uh Emily a question following
up on uh on the what you said at the end
of your of your presentation about the
Paul Politics
as you mentioned
there's this big wave of legislation
right now and um and it's doing as you
said all sorts of things it's promoting
phonics it's in some cases I guess
restricting the use of queuing
um that's fairly detailed I would say
for for legislation
um we've had a moment in the United
States uh the No Child Left Behind
experience I think which is what you're
alluding to
um in 2002
um a bill passed um under George Bush
but it was a bipartisan bill I think it
um I think it had like almost 90 votes
in the U.S Senate
um almost maybe 380 or something like
that in the house unheard of in today's
Times yes yeah right it's a big
bipartisan thing when I think about it I
think I I may be misremembering but I
think I I even remember
um like Ted Kennedy standing next to
George Bush when they they signed signed
this bill you know
okay yes good good okay and then um the
reading first program that came out of
the uh No Child Left Behind
um Bill uh was sort of aimed at the idea
of promoting scientifically based uh
reading approaches
um and so this had a real head of steam
um this was based on a national
assessment of of where the science of
reading was and it had it was um very
far along and very close to what um what
you're describing
um this effort
um uh was you know kind of ran off the
rails I would say
um within uh half a decade or so it
began to you know run off the rails ran
off the rails
um what lessons do you draw
um from that experience what cautions uh
uh are you led to wanna wanna kind of
remark on and what what do you how do
you want what what is our takeaway away
from that lesson what what are your
what's your takeaway from that
experience to help us avoid
um getting into a kind of turning
turning what really is something that I
think everyone could really get behind
as the initial Coalition behind the
national the No Child Left Behind uh
acts suggests uh that you know that what
could turn this into a partisan uh
partisan thing and lead to some of the
promise that we see in these initial
legislative way of sort of sort of not
being realized yeah well certainly for a
lot of people out there uh it's a little
bit deja vu all over again like what's
happening now they're like wait a minute
didn't we do this before so
um and I'll say a couple of things
number one I I do I'm I'm convinced from
all the work that I've Done That What's
Happening Now wouldn't be happening if
reading reading first hadn't happened in
both a positive and a negative way so
one thing that I think is true so
reading first was a basically six
billion dollar effort it was about a
billion oh so we taxpayers invested a
lot of money in trying to get the
so-called science of reading into
schools it's really very similar to
what's happening today
um because and essentially it was
motivated by
scientists and policy makers recognizing
that there was this big gap between
research and practice and we knew a lot
from research and we just needed to get
this into schools and if we could just
get this into schools and get the right
materials into teachers hands we could
make a big difference I think
what's happening now is benefiting from
that because in every school and every
school system there are some people who
really's lives were changed by reading
first like they really did learn
something about how kids learn to read
and they've either you know they've been
trying their hardest to do that or
there's a base of knowledge there so
there is within our system where there's
a huge there's a lot of turnover and all
that there's still a base of Knowledge
from a generation ago now practically
and so I don't think what's happening
now would be happening if we hadn't sort
of established that Baseline and all the
research that was done
um at that point I think the other thing
that happened I really think is that we
had a reaction to reading first so a lot
of what's happened in the year since I
think we had a decade of really like
swinging really far in a different
direction there were a number of things
that people didn't like about the No
Child Left Behind Bill uh there were a
number of things in there that I think
even the people who made the bill
recognize were mistakes right so I think
that there was a lot of reaction against
that there was a lot of political
reaction against the Bush Administration
the Republicans we went from a
republican Administration to a
democratic Administration there were a
lot of things going on here but I think
there were I think mistakes were made
during reading first I think there was
um I think a lot of it was very top down
in nature and I think that's a very
important lesson now and I think that's
why we're at a fragile moment right now
because I think a lot of the
conversation about the science of
reading right now has been coming from
the bottom up it's been a lot of parent
advocacy uh teachers too saying hey some
we have a problem here we need to fix
this problem and they've been sort of
looking up and saying like we need help
from our principals from our
superintendents from our state
legislators and in for in some cases
they were responding but in other cases
they're saying like hey we need
something we need help here and now
that's happening so now we're starting
to get a very much of a top-down I think
good policy I think for the political
scientists on the call I think
ultimately good policy comes from some
really delicate balance between these
two things so I think we're in the midst
of that right now
um but I think it's important to I mean
I think there were some things that were
heavy-handed into top down about reading
first so I think we need to be careful
about top down stuff but again top down
is because people below need the help
um I think that reading first got the
the story about reading first and I
think this actually happened in practice
in a lot of places is that it sort of
focused too much on the decoding part
one of the reasons I decided to give you
that whole explanation about how kids
learn to read is I want you to
understand that this is not just about
phonics right that language
comprehension part is huge
I want people to understand that you
can't just add phonics because that's
not enough and you can't just add
phonics without taking away the stuff
that isn't right about the whole
language Theory so I think in Reading
first time writ large we probably just
didn't do enough of the work on the
language comprehension and the queuing
stuff didn't go away we didn't actually
lose the adherence to the basic beliefs
in the whole language approach and I
think maybe now
maybe the conversation about this and
the research itself is sort of becoming
more nuanced and sophisticated that I'm
hopeful
um that we might be at a good moment and
I'll say one last thing about the
politics I do think that reading first
became associated with because it was a
George you know was a Republican and
phonics has always been seen as sort of
traditional and conservative and
old-fashioned and as soon as that got
associated with phonics and the George
Bush Administration it was easy to
dismiss if you were Progressive if you
were liberal or whatever it was like
push that away what I'm hoping is going
to mediate it now is that
um this is really important to a lot of
people who have a very very wide set of
political beliefs so if you just look at
my Twitter feed it's got people on the
far left and people on the far right and
everywhere in between and I love that I
love that there is that wide swath of
people who are really interested in this
so I hope that what will happen here is
that if it starts to get taken by one
party or another that there'll be a
force being like no no no no no if you
you over here on the far right want to
take this as your issue I'm not going to
let you do that I I'm over here on the
far left and I want this issue is mine
too same thing someone gets very far
left about this no no no this is my
issue too
I'm hoping that that's what's going to
happen but it's possible I'm being too
optimistic
great thank you thanks again thank you
for that response Emily and again thank
you for uh for such an engaging talk
um uh we have a bunch of questions and
again I want to encourage people
um we have a bunch of questions and I
hope we'll get to a bunch more
um so please ask your questions uh with
that I want to turn it over to Eric uh
potashnik who has been uh processing the
the question flow
thank you it's a real pleasure to be
here and um we received lots of comments
uh from people who said that uh that
Emily's podcast was amazing and I
certainly will Echo that it is a
phenomenal experience to listen to it
and so encourage everyone to do that so
one of the questions uh Emily was about
your podcast and where Lucy Calkins
referenced classroom literacy practices
in the 70s and 80s as the antithesis of
exciting and beautiful and so the
question is is one of the reasons why
science and reading wasn't getting much
traction was its image problem that
there was an impression that uh
classroom practices associated with that
are kind of boring and are not going to
stimulate children how important do you
think that Dimension was to why
um it didn't gain more traction in
schools around the country
yes I I think that is a good observation
I think that is definitely part of I
think that the science of reading did
and maybe still does have a little bit
of an image problem I will also say that
I think it's really important when
people are talking about something
that's boring to think about who is it
boring for I think in some cases this
stuff is boring for the adults but not
necessarily boring for the children if
you are in a classroom where kids are
really learning how to read and cracking
the code they're pretty excited about
that and I think some of us can even
remember I know people can remember
those moments where it clicked for them
where they were finally reading it's an
incredibly powerful and exciting thing
for a child to begin to learn how to
read it's really just like a big life
moment
um and I think that a lot of the what we
know is that there's a significant
amount of just details that kids need to
understand in repetition and practice
that can look boring and wrote from the
outside but if it's effective if it is
getting kids to where they need to be
remember the question I kept asking how
does a little kid get there and the
question is you you're not gonna love
reading it's not going to be joyful
beautiful experience if you can't do it
and it is not a joyful beautiful
experience for a lot of kids in a lot of
classrooms where they're really being
expected to figure out a lot of this
stuff on their own they're giving sort
of being given sort of big broad
instruction and some strategies to
figure out the words and it all adds up
for some kids but for a lot of kids it
doesn't add up and again I want to go
back to the equity issue here there are
some kids
who get the help they need outside of
school but there are a lot of kids who
don't and so we're really I think
dramatically
widening the gaps
opportunity gaps very early on in
education when we don't teach kids
directly and explicitly the things we
want them and need them to know
great another question here's a
two-parter and that is are there
particular phonics or decoding programs
that the experts who study the science
of reading Advocate that really identify
and say these are these are the best
practices and then secondly what would
be the advice you would offer to
somebody who finds that the schools
perhaps the schools their children are
in is resistant uh to moving away from
the queuing curriculum what kinds of
advocacy strategies you're finding are
most effective on the ground
so the first question about programs I
get all the time and I'm I'm reluctant
to answer that number one I'm not hiding
anything I don't really even know if I
know the answer to that right but I
think people's immediate
um question is well what do I buy what
do I need to get and I I always want to
tell everyone like hold on let's make
sure you really understand what you're
what you want what you're looking for so
I do think there are some places that
really um do lay out what are the kinds
of things you want to see in a
curriculum
um and I think those are important
there's an organization called the
reading league and they do have like
some rubrics where you can go through
and um evaluate curriculum there are
some entities that actually evaluate
curriculum there are some states that
are starting to do that I mean
Massachusetts is nearby they're starting
to have their own system where it's
called curate where they're going
through and looking at um curriculum and
I think they're really looking at it
with the sort of Science of reading in
mind there are some other organizations
that do it that more look at whether or
not they kind of align with the common
core standards which isn't exactly the
same as looking at whether they really
align with the science of reading but Ed
reports is an organization that does
that so I think it's important to
um
ask just know what questions to ask of a
curriculum
um so I know that's maybe an
unsatisfying answer but also as a
journalist I never want to endorse
products anyway
on the question I hear this all the time
from parents who are concerned and are
getting resistance from their schools
and
um I would say find the other parents
who have the same questions and concerns
you have because they're there and so
find them and it's so much better to go
to the school with more than one of you
not it you know and and I also think
many parents have gone to the school
with these questions and it's just them
sort of against the school I mean they
literally walk into a meeting and
there's like eight people and them and
they get sort of this education educate
as you speak that they don't understand
and then they leave feeling like they're
in an alternate reality and it's like I
think my kid is having trouble reading
but they're telling me all the stuff and
understand what they're saying and
they're saying it's not a problem and I
know that it is so find the other
parents who um
are trying to ask questions and go with
them and I guess take advantage of the
moment because I think there is a
growing awareness of this and so there's
now a lot of resource resources not just
the reporting I've done but there's a
tremendous amount of stuff that's been
written that's really easy to digest and
read and pass around there are teachers
who are writing really great blogs there
are cognitive scientists who are
starting to really learn how to
translate this into practice
I think that's part of the problem too
it still is re you know Research into
practice is very difficult it takes a
long time for research to get into
practice and where the science of
reading is really well established I
think it's less well-established and
well tested that we have like lots of
great curriculum out there that we know
really work we don't because part of the
problem is that balanced literacy has
been so predominant it's really what the
market wanted it's what all the
Publishers were creating it's what
people were buying there's not a huge
number of options when it comes to stuff
that's better aligned with the science
of reading so I think we're in a moment
now where the Market's shaking out we're
going to see a lot of products get
revised we're going to see new products
out there and I think some of these
things will be good and they need to be
tested and a lot of them haven't been
tested yet
great we received a couple of questions
about uh people wanted to know how the
lessons apply to particular groups of
students who might have who might have
special needs so for example
multilingual students or students who
lack a rich vocabulary are there any
ways in which uh the findings of This
research suggest that teaching should be
modified for those groups or or what
you're finding that it works for all
groups of students
well again it's one of the reasons why I
spend time on that simple view of
reading because I think if you even just
think about those questions and then
think about the simple view of reading
you can kind of find your answer right
so there are two big things that are
involved in beginning to reading
comprehension your decoding ability your
ability to read those written words and
your language comprehension so you
clearly have some kids for example a kid
who doesn't speak English who's going to
need more a lot more on the language
comprehension side they're just going to
need a heavy dose of that and they are
not going to do well in a classroom that
is not providing a good base of that and
where they're even getting more help
right so you want lots of conversation
lots of reading out loud lots of talking
lots of oral language but they need the
decoding too there's no difference they
still need to learn how to decode those
written words it's just that they you
know if you think about it they don't
they don't have the benefit of the oral
language ability in that moment that it
clicks like oh yeah I know that word
they might be learning the meaning of
the word at the same time same thing for
kids who just might not have a lot of
vocabulary right this is is why getting
that part of it is so important what is
actually really kind of crazy about all
this is teaching kids how to read the
words is arguably the easy part and
that's the part that we've really been
getting wrong and we've been arguing
about for so long that is actually
arguably easier than all the rest of it
the language comprehension the knowledge
all that stuff that it takes to
comprehend what you read requires years
of schooling and is particularly
susceptible to differences in background
right so Europe what you know the words
you know isn't just what you learn in
school in fact a lot of most of what you
learn is just in your daily life
what's going on in your home who are you
getting a chance to talk to what are the
things you're getting exposed to all of
that kind of stuff so really like
equalizing things on the language
comprehension side is more difficult we
will probably always see that reading
comprehension is associated with family
background and sort of opportunities for
language comprehension but I would just
keep going back to the simple view of
reading again it doesn't say reading is
simple it's a simple view a simple way
to understand a complex process but I
think it helps disentangle what does a
second language learner need what is a
kid who doesn't have a huge vocabulary
need all that kind of stuff
we also received a I guess a cognitive
Science question and that is somebody
wanted to know whether you could compare
the process that goes on in the brain
with learning to read with learning to
read music is that similar or different
I can't answer that question
um I certainly know that learning to
read music is a as often as a meta meta
or in terms of the question of the
explicit instruction that one needs to
learn to read music whether or not like
like literally how that goes on in the
brain I don't know but I think that's
fascinating and then a follow-up is um
is there a parallel to the science of
reading to math instruction is there is
what's what do you know anything about
the state of um of our effort to provide
evidence-based math instruction in the
schools today well I showed you that
book
rebrain
Stannis loss and I'm gonna pronounce his
name wrong he's French but it's
d-e-h-a-e-n-e
um the the first book he written maybe
it's not the first book but before he
wrote that book about reading the brain
he wrote a book about math I'm
forgetting what's called at the moment
and I would say so yes there's there
there is a lot of research about math
and how we learn math and how that works
in the brain and I think that math
instruction suffers from some of the
same problems that reading instruction
has and it has to do with the question
with a sort of resistance in American
Education generally to sort of explicit
in direct instruction I would say the
sort of
emphasis in instruction has more been on
uh uh individual learning learning on
your own discovering things for yourself
a more Progressive approach which I
think is wonderful like that's what I
wanted for my kids when my kids were a
little for sure
um
but I I really think that it leaves a
lot of kids behind there are things that
we can explicitly and directly teach to
kids that we should be and it doesn't
have to be wrote old-fashioned boring
abusive any of these whatever these
ideas are that people have in their head
about that it doesn't have to be done
that way it's not being done that way
there are lots of schools where this
kind of instruction is being done really
well but I think that math and reading
suffer from the same idea that somehow
we don't want to explicitly teach little
children things that we want them to
discover it on their own that we think
that that's better and and I and I I the
the cognitive science research does not
show that to be true not better nor and
not more efficient and efficiency
matters here efficiency really matters
with reading because it's a
multiplicative it's an exponential thing
right so you start to get good at
reading and you get better and better
and better at it by reading and the kids
you just spiral up there's this thing
called the Matthew effect in reading
right the rich get richer and it happens
really fast
kids who get off to a good start in
Reading like reading and then do it more
and like it more and get better at it
and do it more and most of what you know
about language and the vocabulary you
know and the knowledge comes from
reading so if you get to a often not a
good start with reading it's frustrating
it's hard it's but you don't like it you
resist it well you are falling so far
behind not because you're falling behind
you're just like slightly getting a
little later on like this and your peers
are going like this this is the
achievement Gap in America right here
um Emily I'm sorry like just could I
just follow up just just quickly on the
math point because that that's that
seems um it seems I I'm wondering
um I don't know is there a parallel
um podcast to be made uh uh about math
instruction that you know here's really
where the here's what we're doing in the
schools and here's some here's a
narrative about why it happened and why
it makes sense
um what
okay yes sir and I think someone else
should do it because I have a whole
bunch of things I still want to do about
reading no I hear you but what I mean is
is there the same level but not yet
surface to this degree the same level of
science scientific foundation for
thinking about how we teach uh basic
numeracy
um that hasn't yet filtered into to the
teacher training and instruction please
yes I think that yes I do I think that
is the case yes wow that's that's um
that's breaking I'm I'm not a journalist
but that's what's me that strikes me as
somewhat noteworthy actually
um and and you're pretty sure that you
you yeah well I I don't think it's I
don't know
I'm not an expert in that area some
about it um so I don't know that there's
the same level or amount of research and
I don't think well I was just gonna say
there hasn't been the equivalent of a
national reading panel but that's
actually not true there have been some
big synthesis reports about math
instruction
um so yes I actually think this is
really a story that needs to be dug into
well fortunately there's there's a
number of people in the audience maybe
yeah journalism take on take on that
challenge thank you very much soon to be
Yale grads go for it thanks a lot
so there were a number of questions I
think of people just really trying to
understand what this really means in
practice for for their children perhaps
they've already been exposed to to
queuing
um approaches so one question was uh is
exposure to rhyming books is that okay
another one is it okay if young readers
memorize sight words in addition to
sounding Out words is that effective as
long as they're not looking at pictures
as cues people are really I think trying
to understand how do I know if my if my
child if somebody I care about is
learning correctly and and when should I
be concerned that they're being taught
in a way that might undermine their
their uh their development as effective
readers yeah yeah yeah I mean it's true
that I think when you point out these
things it's very it makes a lot of sense
that people get very like anxious and
nervous about it I will say one thing so
lots of kids are very resilient right
like a lot and lots of kids really they
can be taught as cueing stuff and they
they will figure out that the sounding
Out part that one that wonky that's the
best most effective most efficient most
accurate way to know the words and they
get that and they start doing that
um it is I have to say that I've talked
to a lot of tutors reading tutors who
work with middle school and high school
kids sometimes this stuff really reveals
itself when kids are first taken to act
and the SAT because it's like a huge
amount of reading really fast and they
really that's like when some of those
reading problems really get revealed for
the first time to parents and they take
them to tutoring and the tutors say that
breaking these habits are really hard
um and they have to really work on
Breaking the Habit first and this
queuing stuff is stuff that you don't
even necessarily need to be taught it's
what a lot of readers will come up with
on their own in the absence of being
taught how to read the words and they
can't figure it out that said you know
kids are resilient I think like you know
you can and people human beings are very
responsive to good instructions so I
think good instruction really can and
does work and works at all ages I've
tied to a number of adults who really
were subliterate into their 40s and 50s
and got some good instruction and really
were able to read rhyming books are
fantastic like there's all kinds of
things that if you think about
um rhyming books are really like about
language and the facility with language
and understanding words and those are
really good and fine do you want that to
be like what you're using when you're
trying to teach kids how to decode words
no because it's going to be too easy for
them to get get them based on the rhyme
right so it depends it's like for what
purpose you always that's like there are
certain books and certain activities for
certain purposes on the question of
memorizing words so no I think the the
one of the things we really do know is
that whole idea of just like flashcards
memorize the words it's not the most
efficient and effective way to learn the
words is it going to be damaging to all
kids absolutely not because some of
those kids really are teaching
themselves the code through that they're
memorizing the words they're putting
together the spelling the sound of the
meaning and it's making sense but that
is not a good sign if what your kid is
being asked to do in school is just
memorize a lot of words because that is
actually not the best most efficient way
to store them in your long-term now
again some kids really are teaching
themselves and they can use these
pattern books and they can be taught the
queuing strategies and all of that
exposure they put it together and
they're good it's almost like magic like
like my kids
so
um I'll ask a question myself if that's
okay so thanks to your amazing podcast
and uh parental advocacy we are seeing
more and more states that are that are
trying to promote science of reading and
to and to eliminate queuing strategies
and to be effective but of course at the
end of the day the Stow actually has to
happen in the classroom teachers have to
uh change in some cases the way they've
been teaching for many years how
difficult is that how much professional
development is required how many hours
of training what are the challenges to
actually if a state has already made a
commitment they they've listened to your
podcast the parents came to the school
board they said we absolutely want to do
this how hard will it be to go from that
uh commitment at a policy level to
actually making sure this happened in
classrooms consistently over the long
run hard I think it's going to be very
hard and I really worry about that
um I mean it's uh yeah it's going to be
very hard because this is a really big
um amount of knowledge amount for
teachers to learn there are a lot of
things they need to unlearn along the
way
um I'll just sort of report on what
teachers have told me like I hear from
teachers all the time and they do
they're it's almost like these stages of
grief about this like often they resist
at first like oh no no that can't be
I've been teaching kids this way and you
know a lot of them are doing fine and a
lot of them we're doing fine right
because a lot of kids do fine depend
depending on where you are right you
might have most of the kids in your
class refined no matter how you teach in
other places you might have a lot more
kids
so many teachers though have been like
you know I had a gut level feeling that
something wasn't right and a lot of
times they blame themselves I wasn't
doing it well enough I wasn't doing good
enough jobs so I'm gonna work really
hard I'm going to go to more
professional development I'm really
going to do this they work hard do
everything they're supposed to do and
the kid a lot of the kids still aren't
learning so what do you do oh well it
must be the kids uh they're not working
hard enough they're lazy they're not
trying hard enough oh maybe he has a
reading disability oh her mother didn't
read to her enough at home poor girl she
doesn't have enough books in her home
and then and so when when teachers start
to learn about this they start to
realize oh my God I was blaming myself I
was blaming the families I was blaming
the kids but there was a lot of stuff I
didn't know and now I like have a huge
amount I need to know and so you know a
lot of teachers are making Investments
of a huge amount of their time and in
some cases their money to go learn this
stuff and it is you know teaching is a
hard job we have so much of our teachers
the work conditions are great we don't
pay them enough like this is not easy
there are plenty of teachers who are
resisting this for a good reason and one
of the reasons they're resisting it is
like I have heard you telling me before
that this is the new thing I have to
learn and the new thing I have to do and
I'm not interested I'm going to close my
door and do what I've always been doing
and in some cases what they've always
been doing is great they they figured
this out long ago and were teaching when
they were trying to resist all the fads
and all the things going on
unfortunately
we'd love to be able to tell teachers
close your doors and just make your own
professional decisions but so many
teachers haven't learned what they need
to know about how kids learn to read and
they're recognizing that so I think this
is a really really big challenge I guess
I will just say I'm hopeful at the
moment because I think there are a lot
of people out there who are really
committed to it because it's so
important
um Emily uh I just want to say one of
the participants recommended a um a pod
I guess a wet uh I don't know if what it
is a it's a website I guess uh
chalk and talk with an ampersand Yeah
Anna Stokey on uh mathematics education
um yeah and um uh and I just wanted to
know are there any sources that that you
turn to or that you find a specially
interesting any internet uh you know
websites that that you know you would
say someone who wants to know more about
about this other that they would turn
you would recommend they turn to yeah
sure if you go to the sold a story web
page which is soldiastory.org there's a
reading list there and I just put 10
things on it I literally could have put
a hundred but if you start with those 10
things you can go down a rabbit hole for
the rest of your life if you want to if
you just follow the footnotes there's
one paper on there that has you know
like 250 references or something so uh
you'll be good fantastic
um and um we're coming to the end of our
time so are there any sort of
observations or anything you'd like to
like to to say
um kind of to round round out our
discussion
ah wow okay
um well thanks for being interested in
this I know people are interested in it
for a bunch of different reasons and so
I appreciate whatever reason you bring
to the table whether it's your own child
whether you're a teacher and are trying
to learn better whether you're a student
who wants to become a teacher or go into
education policy or go into education
research I do think this is sort of an
all hands on deck kind of situation and
I promise you that this stuff is really
fascinating
um just at an intellectual level for me
doing this work over the past five or
six years has been so gratifying because
it's just really interesting stuff so I
encourage you to go to that reading list
um and and dig in it's just a
fascinating topic awesome thank you so
much Emily I just want to say from all
the all the people at the institution
for social and policy studies there I've
said the name of the center that I
direct I'd like to just thank you so
much if you've spent the day here
meeting with faculty and student
students and everyone I've spoken with
has been really inspired by hearing
about all the things that you've done
and all of your insights into this
important social problem so let me just
say thanks again to the audience thanks
for everyone for attending and for your
excellent questions
tremendously grateful to you for your
time Emily and Eric my good friend Eric
thank you for for your help with the
questions it's it's just um you're so
good at this and uh and I really am
grateful to you for for agreeing to to
take on this responsibility and and
doing it so nicely
um I encourage you to visit the isps
website
isps.yale.edu uh you can go there to
keep up with all isps events and
research and look for announcements
about future events again that's
isps.yale.edu
you can also follow us on Twitter
at isps Yale that's at isbs Yale
um again thank you all for attending uh
thanks again to this to our incredible
staff especially Pam green uh Rick
Harrison and Kira Wisher who helped with
the arrangements associated with Emily's
visit and today's uh webinar
um with that I conclude today's event
have a great evening and I look forward
to seeing the participants at future
isps events